people wait nervously in line to withdraw their savings in donetsk eastern ukraine they'd rather rely on hard cash news that mainly foreign banks had closed their doors and Kiev has people here worried skazala stored as a people say that all bank accounts will be blocked by tomorrow and phones will most likely be blocked to a say you have to urgently withdraw money because technical faults might make it impossible to withdraw or transfer money yes this I'm here because of panic but how the panic started I don't know most banks have since reopened interest rates for Ukraine's national debt have fallen and the currency has firmed slightly but Kiev faces deep economic uncertainty Standard & Poor's has downgraded its rating again and warned of possible debt default russia says a question mark hangs over the next tranche of aid until the shape of the next government is clear further increasing concerns of Kiev defaulting